في كياب مثل باقي انحاء اوكرانيا يتخوف
الاوكرانيون مما يسمونه بالهدوء الذي
يسبقه العاصفه ويقصدون بهذه العاصفه تخوف
تخوف عفوا وخشتهم من عوده العمليات
العسكريه الميدانيه الروسيه مطلعه الربيع
القادم على الرغم من ان معنوويات
الاوكرانيين ارتفعت نوعا ما في الايام
القليله الماضيه بسبب الدعم العسكري
الغربي الثقيل لاوكرانيا واخبار قرب وصول
هذه الدبابات الى انهم يتخوفون كثيرا من
حجم الرد الاوكراني عنده وصول هذه
الدبابات لكن في نفس الوقت يعولون عليها
من اجل تغيير معطيات وتفاصيل المعركه
الميدانيه جددت مره ثانيه
همم
تبعد عفوا نحو همم خمس كيلومترات فقط على
مدينه الاستراتيجيه تريد مجموعه فاجر
اختراق هذه من اجل فتح الطريق امام الجيش
النظامي الروسي للوصول الى مدينه كرامتوس
وقطع الامدادات على كل القوات الاوكرانيه
لجهه المقابله لن تؤكد القوات الاوكرانيه
ولم فني سقوط مدينه
بلاهاودتني لكن في نفس الوقت اكدت انها
استطاعت همم صد مجموعه فاجنر في اكثر من
مره وفي اكثر من قريه في مدينه باخموت وفي
بعض القرى في مقاطعه دونالدز كل هذا شرقا
اذا توجهنا جنوبا تشدد القصف على مدينه
زامبو المدفعيه الثقيله والصواريخ بعيده
المدى القادمه من السفن الحربيه الموجوده
في البحر الاسود ونفس الامر وقع في مدينه
خيرسون منذ يومين تعرضت لقصف روسي ثقيل
مكثف جدا من اسفرها على عدد كبير من همم
القتلى والجرحى تعرض مستشفى ومركز بريدي
وبعد المصارف حسب الروايه الاوكرانيه
للقصف المكثف المتكرر منذ ايام